in the economic war with ukraine's
allies this is russia's greatest weapon
the nordstream one pipeline supplying
germany and western europe with precious
natural gas but 12 hours before it was
due to reopen after a three-day closure
for maintenance came news it will stay
shut indefinitely
nordstrom is the main pipeline through
which gas prompt supplies its gas into
northwest europe
it can
and historically did deliver something
like
165 million cubic meters per day into
germany
um more recently it's been doing 33 and
now it's doing nothing in the final
hours before it's meant to start up
they've yet again found found something
and i think the market will be largely
interpreted in this as as
a fabrication
this is what gazprom says is the problem
oil leaks in the system that need
attention
but russia's announcement came hours
after g7 nation stepped up sanctions
announcing a potential price cap on
russian oil exports
it will prevent putin from profiteering
from the very high oil prices
and equally importantly it will mean
that we will be able to collectively and
we can bring other countries
uh as well that's what we've just agreed
amongst the g7 finance ministers
protect our citizens from oil price
shocks next year
a prolonged closure of nordstrom 1 will
further inflate gas prices and heighten
anxiety about the economic implications
and cost of living here and across the
continent
russia has proved again that with a turn
of the gas tap it can tighten the
squeeze on its enemy's friends paul
kelso sky news